ladies and gentlemen the host of the
Academy's scientific and technical
awards show Jennifer Garner
two weeks ago on February 14th the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences handed out its scientific and
technical awards in Pasadena I hosted
the event and what better way for a girl
to spend Valentine's Day here's a recap
of the winners you know as an audio
company it's an exceptional honor to be
honored for technical achievement in a
motion picture industry that's just
incredible and I'd like to thank the
Academy and everybody at Digidesign
Abbott technology our parent company who
contributed so heavily - making ProTools
what it is today well supposedly I've
been given this beautiful thing for some
motion control hardware and software
that I've developed over the last few
years but I know fully well that if it
weren't for the efforts of countless
people who have staked their livelihood
and the reputation on the use of my
equipment but I would never have gotten
this thing so thanks Academy thanks
awards committee this is one heck of a
Valentine thank you ladies and gentlemen
members of the Academy thank you all
most sincerely this is a great great
honor I think all of us who are
fortunate enough to stand up here this
evening and on other similar nights in
past years know that so much of what we
do is a result of contributions from
other sources thank you so much for this
it is truly a great award
I want to congratulate all the award
winners from that night and especially
the three who took home Oscars your
skill and talent are truly amazing thank
you please welcome the star of who's
all-mighty Jim Carrey